So the most important thing to remember when we say a problem is NP complete
is the NP-completeness equation which says that
NP-Complete means that a problem is in NP and
its NP-Hard.
Alright, so based on that
knowing that graph partition is NP-Complete means that Yes, graph partition is NP-hard.
And based on what we said about NP-hardness, a polynomial time solution
to graph partition would solve everything in NP.
We also know specifically that any problem like clique that we know is in NP can be reduced to it.
so a solution to graph partitioning would solve clique specifically.
>From this part of the NP-completeness equation
we know that graph partitioning is in NP.
And from what we know about NP means that an exponential time solution exists to graph partitioning
And that it can be reduced to SAT. If somebody could solve SAT for us that would also let us solve graph partitioning.
So we actually know all of these things by virtue that graph partitioning is NP-complete.